if I'm running an experiment but is an
ethical experiment what's an unethical
experiment to run on users to what
extent should users be aware of the fact
that they're in experiments how am I
going to recognize an address by a
seasoned the data that my machines
learning from and that's just scratching
the surface there's going to be plenty
of other questions that are going to be
raised in the next few years about how
we design these systems in a way that is
respectful of our users you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using them
[Music]
developing complex artificial
intelligent systems in a lab as a
challenging task but what happens when
they go into production and interact
with real humans that's what researchers
like dr. Fernando Diaz a principal
research manager at Microsoft Research
Montreal want to know he and his
colleagues are trying to understand and
address the social implications of these
systems as they enter the open world
today dr. Diaz shares his insights on
the kinds of questions we need to be
asking about artificial intelligence and
its impact on society he also talks
about how algorithms can affect your
taste in music and why now more than
ever
computer science education needs to
teach ethics along with algorithms that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Fernando Diaz welcome to the podcast
thank you
you're a principal research manager at
Microsoft Research Montreal and you work
in artificial intelligence and search
and information retrieval but you're
also really involved in fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
or fate research so in broad strokes and
we'll get specific in a bit what gets
you up in the morning what are the big
questions you want answers to and the
big problems you'd like to solve well a
lot of these systems that we're building
are extremely successful so information
retrieval or web search computer vision
these are all been developed over the
course of many many decades and they're
certainly got production eyes and users
are starting to see them on a daily
basis what we haven't thought so much
about in designing these systems is as
computer scientists what is the social
context in which these things are being
used and so my concern here is better
understanding you know what are the
social implications of these systems
we're building how will the social
context in which these systems are used
affect not just our own metrics like
precision or recall but also society at
large and I think this is something
that's really coming to a 4/4 computer
scientists because a lot of these
techniques that have been developed in
isolation are just starting to be
commercialized right now so you're a
computer scientist by training and
you've done research in information
retrieval statistical methods machine
learning but you've lately become very
interested in the interface of these AI
systems and society particularly what
happens when AI hits production or as
some people say the open world why this
interest for you now what questions are
you asking what piqued your interest in
going this direction that's a great
question so I obviously went to graduate
school and got a PhD and was studying
these systems at a pretty abstract level
and really conducting experiments with
data that was static and collected
offline and soon after graduate school I
came into Industrial Research Lab and
was working with production teams that
were implementing the techniques that
I was studying in graduate school and
you begin to realize that when you take
these algorithms and you scale them out
and you put them in front of real users
a lot of the basic assumptions that you
are making in the laboratory were not
well supported in reality and so that
was sort of a check for me in terms of
my research agenda really coming back to
the first principles and trying to
understand better okay what is the
problem here what exactly do I need to
be measuring and how do i optimize for
this right metric whatever that might be
so you were at Microsoft Research before
and then you took a bit of a break and
then you came back you started in New
York and now you're in Montreal what
brought you back so I had actually after
graduate school started my industrial
research career in Montreal and for
various reasons I had to relocate out of
Montreal but even while I lived here I
recognized that this city itself in
Canada in general is a pretty rich
tradition very strong computer science
research machine learning research and
in the back of my head like I've always
wanted to come back to participate in
that and so when the opportunity arose
to rejoin Microsoft research in a new
Montreal lab it was the perfect fit
especially since the lab itself focuses
on artificial intelligence the city
itself is really going through a
blossoming of AI research and being part
of that and contributing my voice to
that broader conversation is something
that just made sense to me let's talk
about Montreal for a minute it's become
a global hotspot in artificial
intelligence research and the goal of
the MSR Montreal lab is very specific
they want to teach machines to read
think and communicate like humans give
us your particular take on where we are
on this quest and how your research
interests align with what the Montreal
lab is doing well I think part of the
reason there's a research lab in that
area is the fact that there are still a
lot of unanswered questions with respect
to how to engineer these systems and I
think it will require more than just
folks from natural language processing
or more than just folks from dialogue or
reinforcement learning it really
requires
combination of those and I think that's
one of the things that makes this lab
especially unique now my role is to come
into this lab and hopefully add to that
conversation by providing a perspective
of well how will these systems actually
behave when they're in a human context
because like I said before it's very
easy to design these systems in
isolation and then when you deploy them
realize that there were some very strong
assumptions in the experiments you are
conducting now the role of the group
that I'm building is to try to sort of
anticipate some of these questions and
other engineer our systems to be robust
to say differences in the populations
that I might be interacting with or in
the corpora that I might be gaining
knowledge from what is the group you're
building there so the group that I'm
building is sort of a sibling
organization of the fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
group that we started in New York City a
few years ago the focus will be on
studying the social implications of
artificial intelligence in society and
so that group will be composed of folks
with a technical computer science
background but also a technical
background from related disciplines such
as sociology and so the idea here being
that in order for computer scientists to
better understand and address the social
implications they really need experts in
you know sociology they need experts in
anthropology etc to give us the insight
into those things that we have not been
measuring so well so far yeah let's talk
about that the fairness accountability
transparency and ethics application to a
variety of artificial intelligence and
machine learning technology research is
super-important right now and as you
bring up this is because not all corner
cases can be explored in the lab and
there are some unintended consequences
along with the intended ones that can
surprise people and so this community
doing research in this area is quite
diverse in terms of academic training
what do each of these experts bring to
the mix when they're looking at fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
so somebody from a social science
background will
have a better understanding of
technology use in general how it's used
or misused and how people just react to
certain tools that we provide them
somebody from a legal background might
be able to better comment on the policy
implications of certain technologies
that are being developed or really gives
us a deeper understanding of what we
mean when we talk about something like
fairness and then folks from the
computer science community really
understand the systems that are being
developed and may be able to
conceptualize some of the constraints
such as fairness and incorporate them
into the system but it really requires
these multiple perspectives to come up
with better approaches to designing
these systems let's go back to some
stuff you've done in the past and are
still working on now information access
systems and search engine information
retrieval and in a paper you wrote you
suggest that there's a gap between
studying these systems and implementing
them but you also make a sort of
provocative statement that there are
open problems that are better addressed
by academia than industry what kinds of
problems are those and why do you make
that statement what are the things that
happens in information access research
is you have academics who have
contributed the community a lot but
these days a lot of the say web search
research is happening at the big mobile
search companies where they have the
data they have the users etc and a lot
of times the academics don't have access
to the experimentation platforms or the
data and so there's a disparity in terms
of the amount of rigor you can do in
your research so what I was claiming in
that article was that you know well
academics even though they don't have
that amount of data they do have a broad
set of collaborators that you may not
find at the bigger search engine
companies so at a university you have
access to sociologists and other
departments you have access to economics
professors all of these are potential
collaborators which will help you
understand the problem from multiple
different perspectives instead of
perhaps one very specific perspective
which you might have in a web search
policy I think data set releases are one
strategy one of the other approaches
that I think are one of the other
types of scientific platforms that one
would not have in academia is the
experimentation so I can actually run a
be test you can run controlled
experiments with large populations of
users which doesn't really exist in a
data set release no that's true
and so one of the things that I think is
worth exploring is how do we actually
provide access to academics for doing
that sort of controlled experimentation
interesting that happened in bits and
pieces here and there but I think this
is really something that we as an
industrial researcher can think about
providing okay let's go back to data
let's talk about data for a minute in
machine learning circles there seems to
be some consensus that it's no longer
good enough just to have big data and I
use that with air quotes around it but
it also has to be good data or unbiased
data which is part of that mix so we
know that there's probable bias in a lot
of these big data sets and we need to
fix that people are now talking about
trying to remove bias through things
like search engine audits and fairness
aware algorithms in that kind of thing
how do you do that one of the reasons
were concerned about bias and data is
that the Train model will be biased when
it's deployed and so step one is to be
able to detect whether or not the
actions of artificial intelligence are
bias themselves and if they are how do I
go back and retrain that algorithm or
add constraints the algorithms so it
doesn't learn the biases from the data
and so my work to date has focused
primarily on the measurement side of
things on the measurement side of things
it has more to do with understanding the
users that are coming into the system
what they're asking for and whether or
not the system by virtue of the fact of
who the user is or what population
they're coming from is behaving in a way
that you would consider biased and that
requires a lot of the expertise from the
information retrieval community who have
been thinking a lot about measurement
and evaluation for almost since the
beginning of the research agenda of the
communities in the fifties
and so this is what makes it a good
natural fit between auditing and
measurement and information retrieval so
as we've discussed bias has become a bit
of a buzzword in data science and AI
research but you've suggested there are
other social issues besides bias that
also need to be addressed what are some
of these issues and how can your
research help yeah I do think that bias
is a very important problem but I think
one of the reasons why I talk about the
social implications of AI is because I
think bi is just one of the social
implications that we can detect there
are certainly others so a pretty clear
one is transparency so how do i how do I
make the algorithms decisions about what
it's doing transparent to the user so
that the user feels a little bit more in
control of the situation when they're
actually trying to cooperate with an
algorithm a second one would be sort of
the cultural implications of algorithms
so this happens more in context of say
movie or music recommendations so I'm
building this big system to recommend
music to individuals what are the
longer-term cultural implications of
deploying these recommendation algorithm
if I know that recommending certain
musicians will push somebody's musical
tastes in certain directions in the long
term what does this mean for the
creation or curation of culture the
other side of that problem is that music
recommendation algorithms can really
have profound effects on the creators
and musicians themselves and so I might
as a computer scientist say well this is
the best algorithm for music
recommendation I'm just going to deploy
it but as computer scientists we haven't
really thought about what are the
effects on the actual creators I think
that for me is when that is especially a
salient so on that thread then how might
you craft a research project that would
ask these questions and how would you do
your research there right so let's take
this example of music recommendation so
you can imagine sitting down with
musicians and better understanding like
what is important to them what do they
feel like they're getting out of a
system how do they feel like they're in
control or out of control in a
recommendation system and sitting down
with folks
who come more from the sociology or
anthropology backgrounds media studies
to help me as a computer scientist
understand what that big population of
musicians look like and then I can as a
computer scientist sit down and try to
better understand well how do I design
an algorithm which will both satisfy my
listeners as well as satisfy my
musicians hmm now I think even posing it
that way is extremely reductive and so
that's why I wish there was somebody in
the room from one of these other
disciplines to point out and say well
Fernando you know about this so given
the nature of the research you do and
all the things you see as a result is
there anything that we should be
concerned about anything that keeps you
up at night one of the things that does
concern me is the fact that a lot of
these techniques that were developing as
a research community are being put out
and then deployed into production within
a matter of days or weeks by people who
perhaps we're not the original
experimenters now there's nothing wrong
with open science but I do think that we
need to be a bit more cognizant and
aware of the facts that our algorithms
will have before we rush to deploy them
and what I'm concerned about is that
we're sort of quickly pushing out newer
newer algorithms without having a deeper
understanding of those implications
Microsoft research has a reputation for
working closely with academic
institutions and I know that education
is something you're passionate about so
talk about what's going on in fate or
fairness accountability transparency and
ethics education and tell us your vision
for the future of Education in this area
so I think when I went to graduate
school or even undergraduate for career
science one of the things that was not
really taught so well was ethics or the
social implications of the technologies
that we're developing and I think part
of the reason for that is that you know
you're studying operating systems or
you're studying information retrieval at
an abstract level you're not really
thinking about the context in which is
are going to be deployed and to be
honest the class is hard enough having
to just think of
the core algorithms and so I think at
least when I was trained and even now
like understanding the social
implications and social responsibility
but you have as an engineer or scientist
do not really make it into the
conversation and so I think that's being
recognized now i think i think that
computer science departments are
starting to develop curricula around
ethics and computer science and so i
think students are starting to be
trained my concern though is that you
know we already have a lot of people out
there developing systems that have not
gone through that training on top of
that there's not a lot I mean you don't
need a computer science PhD in order to
you know start up a company so that part
of the you know who's not covered by
Education there's another thing that
keeps me up at night but in terms of the
education side of things I think as
somebody who's been in an industrial
research lab I can provide that
perspective to students when I'm in the
classroom so to better understand not
just the practical implications of
deploying a machine learning system at
scale but also the social and ethical
implications of deploying machine
learning system at scale and this is
exactly in search of questions I alluded
to before if I'm running an experiment
but there's an ethical experiment what's
an unethical experiment to run on users
to what extent should users be aware of
the fact that they're in experiments how
am I going to recognize and address by
seizing the data that my machine is
learning from and that's just scratching
the surface there's going to be plenty
of other questions that are going to be
raised in the next few years about how
we design these systems in a way that is
respectful of our users you know you see
the history of other areas for example
medicine and the Hippocratic oath first
do no harm and also the the systems that
are set up in place to help ensure that
people aren't harmed and we think
naturally about that with physical
trials and it's just really encouraging
to know that we're starting to think
about that in artificial intelligence
deployment at large scale even though we
don't have like an FDA for AI there's
movement yeah and I think it's important
to understand that that movement has
happened in other disciplines as you
said and so it's not like we're going
through this for the first time and so
to the extent that we can reach out to
folks in the medical ethics community or
folks in the social sciences they can
help us develop what it means to be a
responsible computer scientist I mean if
we were starting from ground zero like
that's especially daunting but I think
we do have collaborators across the
disciplines that can help us with this
problem so as we close Fernando what's
on the horizon for the next generation
of researchers in your I know that's a
big question but at least what thoughts
or advice might you leave with our
listeners many of whom are aspiring
researchers who might have an interest
in the social impact of AI so I think
for folks interested in that area
specifically I think a lot of the
research that's happening right now is
really day one of a much much longer
research agenda I think it's an
extremely exciting area to be involved
in because while we're starting to ask
the fundamental questions now I also
think that there's a lot of additional
fundamental questions that have yet to
be asked by exactly those young
researchers right now I think in terms
of the social impact of that research
it's potentially very large because
there are a lot of these systems that
are already deployed and so your ability
to be involved in and say a product like
a search engine that has social impacts
and to correct those things is extremely
powerful yeah so it's a great time to be
a young researcher Fernando Diaz it's
been great talking to you and it's super
encouraging so thanks for taking time to
talk to us today thank you very much
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Fernando Diaz
and his research on fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
in computer science visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]